i i i can confirm that that would never
happen in japan yeah uh because i i
didn't have that much of a stressful
situation uh but something
kind of similar happened to me recently
yeah so uh recently we uh we went on a
trip together
and after the trip i was meant to fly to
america
fly to america to uh meet sydney's
family because i haven't seen them since
before covert so i wanted to see them
once before i get married and become one
big happy family uh so i had the tickets
booked and because the schedule was so
tight i
had pre-packed all of my travel stuff
before going on the trip with the boys
basically
um
sydney uh flew out i believe like a week
before me
so she she she had she had she had flown
off already right
uh and i remember i packed everything
before and i put my passport in my
travel bag right and uh it's and i
remember coming home and i remember
being absolutely knackered from coming
back from this uh boys trip um and then
i was just like checking everything was
ready to go ready to fly in like a day
or two um and then i noticed the bag is
missing
oh [ __ ] and then i start panicking
because i know the most like if there's
one document i need it's my passport
yeah right especially because i'm
getting married in two months i can't
believe my [ __ ] passport i need to
fly back to the uk um like such [ __ ]
searching around the house and
everything and i'm just like
she better not have
she better not have
and i phone her i phone her and uh she's
she's asleep and it's um it's 2 am right
and she's like why the [ __ ] up she's
just i give her like i give her like 10
phone calls like she's not picking up
phone her mom she's not picking up
luckily luckily um luckily her dad was
still awake luckily i'm just like
russell i need you i need you to do me a
massive favor uh can you wake sydney up
now can you wake sydney up right now
right now
and so yeah he rushes over he wakes in
the oven like sydney do you have the bag
do you have the bag cindy and she's like
this is not the time to be asleep you
need to wake up now i need to check that
you have the [ __ ] ask a travel bag
okay do you have it and she's just like
um yeah yeah yeah i have it i'm like is
my passport in there and she was like
oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
and so i and so
like she like
like i don't know why she had never used
his back which like this is the one time
she decided to use this as a travel bag
um and unfortunately she didn't check
the contents of the bag so who doesn't
check a bag
like nothing else in this bag was it was
it just a passport in the back uh it was
my passport and my other like vaccine
travel documents that i needed so
basically all everything you needed
so yeah so so everything i needed to
travel out of japan
so it was like empties from like the
front pocket would have like literally
like the one that everything i needed my
life my life i'm your proof for
existence yeah my brain of existence in
japan right and so i'm and so we're like
trying to like plan this out to be like
can i make this flight if i if we like
do a frame perfect like frame perfect
drop of this to like [ __ ] dhl all
right
like
and we're like what's the closest dhl
okay so it's it's this place we can go
home you can you can wake up tomorrow
and go get it and then i've realized
unfortunately it's america
and um they don't they don't work on the
weekends yeah so i'm like oh [ __ ] i have
to wait two days before they can even
put the drop off even if even if dhl are
like super on point which they were
actually dhl will like very fast
um
i'm i'm still not gonna get it in time
so
i have to like uh if i want to go to
america here's the strat yeah i i have
to like delay i have to like change the
flight
uh so that was stressful enough not
having my passport on me right yeah
um so i remember phoning up a a
to be like
look i'm in the situation now like i
don't know if i don't know if i qualify
for a change of flight because the thing
is like i believe i i bought a flexible
ticket right right so sorry i wasn't i
wasn't i didn't buy one on like i didn't
i didn't buy a ticket
on like some random [ __ ] site i
bought it from a a itself right
um and so i thought paying like a bit of
a premium price as opposed to buying
from like [ __ ] skyscanner or whatever
that i you know there was a little bit
of wiggle room on that right um because
it wasn't a cheap ticket and like like i
don't know why flying to america right
now is so [ __ ] expensive from like
everywhere because it was it was it was
like the cheap what the cheapest economy
ticket they had and it was still like
[ __ ] like almost like a grand or like
two grand i can't [ __ ] remember it's
like yeah one way
yeah yeah yeah
on one-way flights they're weirdly
expensive return flights are like
weirdly more
like less expensive yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's something to do with how
long you're gone and there's there's
different price points based on if
you're flying with the same carrier and
how far apart you're flying yeah there's
some really strange rules yeah ticket
price yeah so i i phone up a a and i'm
like look here's his situation can i
change my flights uh can i change my
flight to you know a day a few days
after or whatever's whatever's
convenient and they're like yes there's
a flight on x day uh that's still
available i still got seats and i'm like
great
can i change to that flight um how much
how much would it cost would it cost
anything and uh i remember her like
hearing like the
like the keyboard tapping
and then
she pauses
and she pauses and she's just like
um
hold on can i i need to go see the
manager quickly oh my gosh um and i'm
like that's that's that's that's not a
good sign that's not a good [ __ ]
thing in japan yeah yeah anything needs
to manage yeah yeah so i'm like oh man
how how many hundreds of dollars am i
gonna have to like [ __ ] pay to like
change my flights yeah um and then like
i wait for like five minutes i'm like
okay you know i can afford like a few
hundred dollars luckily enough um
because i really want to go see their
family um and then she comes back
and then uh and then she's like okay i
have just confirmed my manager if you
would like to change uh your plane
ticket to this date uh it is
four thousand dollars
what and um and i was i was like
uh can can you can you repeat that
should you repeat that
could could you repeat could you repeat
that i couldn't make any functions
because they because they said it in
because they said they're in yen right
because they said in the end i was just
like four hundred thousand yeah so i was
like uh my my my yen my my japanese must
be rusty because i think i think there's
i must have missed there must be some
static yeah
because i think like is is that what it
is in japanese i must have added an
extra zero in my head because that is
that is not 400 000 yen i must have
heard 40 000 yen yeah and uh just
misheard so i was like could you repeat
that please
and then they repeated that and i was
just like so to confirm in english that
is four hundred thousand yen right
because i'm like like i'm like my hunger
is not josue enough i'm copying him
right now my hunger is definitely not
josue enough right now i'm mishearing
this right oh my god
and um
and she was and and then she was like
yes it is 400 000
uh yen and i was like
how is this possible and and
and she was like uh i apologize um
uh because because
it's it's it's there's a small change
free and like the tax is different like
i couldn't understand like no matter
what she says there is no justification
for an increase in ford
like a flex ticket and somehow it ended
up costing more than the original ticket
yeah yeah like you're not you're not you
didn't like upgrade the business class
right no no no like that's that's the
kind of price this was economy and now
it's just like is that 4 000 yen
on top of the two like no is that a
thousand yeah is that like the four
thousand on top of the ticket that i
just already paid for and she was like
yes
wow so so so it's a five thousand dollar
one weight yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
and so like i'm like there is no [ __ ]
way this makes sense so i go on [ __ ]
sky scanner like i i as azure on the
call as we're on the call and i'm just
like i can see i can buy a ticket on
your website
for two thousand dollars like a new
ticket for two thousand dollars how does
it make sense
that you are charging me four thousand
dollars to change my ticket change it
change it right and she was like i
apologize sir it's just that's just how
the system works it's the up charge for
changing the ticket and i'm just like
and i'm just like okay
so it's cheaper for me to buy a new
ticket even if it's like double the
price at this point from what i
originally paid can i get
a refund for the original picket item
for the original ticket
um
for the original ticket i paid uh in
order to get to get the refund back so i
can buy a new ticket and she was like oh
yes
the
the cancellation fee
will be 900 900 dollars
[Music]
how does that application
how does that work
flexible ticket isn't the whole point of
these things like small tickets means
you can change it you can't refund it
some of them like you some of them you
can you can change it some of them do
and i was just like
am i talking to the circus right now
like that i don't like that i didn't say
that but that's what i wanted to say
you're not the clown
you are the whole circumstance
of a clown
so my choices are either to pay four
thousand dollars uh to change my ticket
or to
to
or to like get 900 to pay 900 dollars to
cancel with tickets uh and then like buy
a 2014 new two thousand dollar ticket
and i'm just like
i am not doing this i like i'd like so
for the first time in my life i was like
can i speak to the manager
like
i like because the thing is i am not the
type of guy who goes karen of course
okay i am not the type of guy
but they were taking the piss i mean i
think anyone in that situation would go
karen mode yeah that's [ __ ]
ridiculous yeah yeah right so i asked
for the manager and like it was the
reasoning for like the up charge of that
much is because i wanted the flights
within like if if i if i had waited i
believe like
i believe like eight days eight or nine
days then it would be a lot cheaper
because there was this like window yeah
where i wanted to change the flight to
even though there were flights available
and the flight tickets which was cheaper
to buy new
changing to that
changing to within that date range meant
that they had to up charge the tickets
right so and there was nothing that
which still doesn't make sense yes which
still doesn't make sense so there was
nothing there was nothing i could do
about it i i talked to the manager i was
like look is there anything you can do
at all because i like i'm not i'm not
lying but this is ridiculous yeah you
are not giving me any way out
you are not giving me a solution my
solution is i pay 900 to pay two
thousand dollars
[Music]
like like like you you're not literally
like the enter the lottery to buy the
ticket yeah yeah yeah yeah um so so
unfortunately i didn't get a solution i
lost a thousand i i lost 900 uh to
cancel my ticket and i flew to england
for a fraction of the price for this
headache to uh go to america christ um
so yeah unfortunately um i don't know i
don't know what's going on with flights
to america it's insane right now yeah i
was trying to get flights from the
inflation dude yeah flash from the uk to
america as well it was crazy expensive
[ __ ] yeah meanwhile flights to from
tokyo to london we're like it was like
one thousand dollars for business
what the [ __ ] going on
what's happening no one's wanting to go
to the uk right now i think no one wants
to go from tokyo as well that's true